you  never meet your heroes well  I did  and it was awesome  the Avengers were everything I imagined  hello San Francisco Thor Tony check it  out  at once try to keep up  this just got a whole lot more  interesting let's make this quick  secure the bridge those weapons can't  get into the city are you set him up  door what's your status there are humans  trapped lots of small Angry Men with  Scottie is that a joke the door make a  joke  [Music]  Tony no are the cables cap what's going  on over there start to chimera what's  your status should head back  no stay on task there's  on this bridge  [Music]  some say they were set up others call  them murderers do the Avengers pose a  danger to society that was the question  Bruce that was the question  well we all lost something that day but  that's not how this story ends  [Music]  well what are we waiting for  [Music]